oh wait it's on woohoo
welcome everybody
so uh This Is How does hot reload even
work
um
I am kind of going to tell you a little
bit of it I can't tell you everything
because it takes too long
um
I'm going to tell you the bit that I
found really interesting when I learned
this as part of having to work on hot
reload so
I hope you find it interesting too but
hot reload is a little bit of a funny
term because it is partly a feature and
it is partly a little bit marketing so
just to be very clear
the bit of hot reload I'm talking about
is applying changes
that we make to code into a.net assembly
while it's running
I'm not going to talk about all of these
things
but later when I ask for questions if
any of them are interesting there's some
hints feel free there is way more to
this there's lots of messy details and
I'm just got a completely gloss over
them for the purposes of time
so the key thing here is a.net assembly
and so before I can tell you how hot
reload works I have to tell you what
a.net assembly is
maybe you know maybe you don't
if you're going to find out so what's in
a.net assembly so this is a screenshot
of ilspy uh maybe some of you have used
it it's an awesome open source project
you should
a.net assembly consists of
two main parts there is metadata the
right metadata meaning data describing
the thing so this describes your dll
specifically in the metadata there is
metadata tables that's what we'll be
looking at and then of course there's
your code
they're the two things in an assembly
and of course hopefully we all know your
c-sharp code is not really in the
assembly it's actually IL and sadly we
have to talk a little bit about IL which
is
sad because I try to avoid it in life
but sometimes you can't
so let's talk about metadata tables
this is ilspy's view of the metadata
tables and I look at this
and I see that they're called tables and
I look at these grids with columns and
rows and I think
this looks like a relational database
and if this was a database conference I
might be kicked out for saying that
there's a relational database inside
your.net assembly
if this was a.net conference I might get
kicked out for that too but I think
there's a little relational database at
the start of your dotted assembly
there are primary keys
this is a metadata token
uh o20001
I think that was the right number Rose
this is the primary key of this Row in
the type def table type def meeting type
definition if you look across to the
name column there's module we'll ignore
that don't know what that is but the
next row says program that's the program
class
so there's a row in a database that
describes the program class and it has a
primary key of
o20001
yeah two good sorry I don't have my
glasses on
um
there's also foreign keys so
part of types is methods and so we have
a method list
column in our database and if we look at
row two we can see method list is 06001
and if we look across at the method
table
there's a primary key 060001 so that's a
foreign key now it's kind of a weird
foreign key because it's kind of
backwards right normally you would say
well if you were designing a database
the method uh table should have a field
that maps to the type def table so I get
that it's a bit funny but there's lots
of compromises made in this mini
relational database
for two main reasons number one is
efficiency we want to store
essentially store as little data as
possible because we produce a lot of dll
files and they can get very big because
you all of you write lots of code so we
want the metadata to be as small as it
can be and then the other reason is
efficiency we have to read this in
for every dll as part of running the
code and so we want to be able to read
it efficiently
and the way this is achieved is there's
two well there's one trick and one
assumption so the trick is
in the metadata token so what I
described as a primary key
it's an integer right four byte number
and
if you're one of these annoying
developers who likes to be really
performant which of course people who
design things like the ecma 335 spec
tend to be
you see an integer and you think how
much stuff can I cram in there so
there's four bytes the first byte tells
you the table that this primary key
comes from
that's really weird for databases I get
it
go with me and then the next three bytes
tell you the row number
so this does mean that there's a limit
to how many methods you can put in
your.net assembly because once you've
got more than three bytes worth
bad luck compiler there's a limit to how
many strings you can put in same reason
I actually we actually hit this limit in
rosin in our test classes it's actually
quite funny we have to split them up
into multiple projects but so these
these primary keys
the trick to them is that they encode in
the ID
what table they come from
so if we look at this method
this methodless method list column which
is actually a terrible example for what
I'm saying because the column is called
method list like where else is it going
to point but you know
you could imagine maybe it said member
list and it was just a list of members
that could be any type
we couldn't know the type from the ID
right 06 that points to the method table
uh say this field list that's o4 zero
zero zero zero
there's no fields in this type so
there's no row zero zero means nothing
but o4
I don't know because I haven't read the
spec but I suspect the field table is
table four
if we look at base type O one o o d
so you start to look at these these
database tables of lots and lots of
funny numbers and bytes and you think
who could understand this and actually
they kind of start to make sense scarily
enough and if we go look up o1 the 01
table which is the type reference so
there's types defined in your assembly
and there's types of reference buyer
assembly and they're stored separately
so we go look up the type reference
table we find a record that says 01 OD
and its name is object and that makes
sense because
program class inherits from object
now in C sharp we don't need to specify
that right it's assumed
in.net in metadata describing your dll
it's not C sharp so that assumption
maybe doesn't exist so this dll clearly
says there's a typical program it
inherits from object and in fact we can
go further with that and I'll show you
in a minute but like that 23001 actually
points to the dll but object was found
in there's no assumptions in here at all
which is
something to remember because it's a bit
weird C sharp is high level language
this is you know it's not a language but
like
it's much more low level
but so using this trick we get really
expressive
uh data which lets us have less data
which is good for our efficiency thing
so for example
there's a table that stores uh
attributes you know you put attribute of
a method a property you type Etc there's
a table that stores them it has a more
normal foreign key it has a parent
column the parent for any attribute
tells you which thing the attribute is
applied to
and
that's all it needs all it needs is a
parent
column that is a token and those tokens
they already tell you what type of
object it is and so you know the little
wires go off and whatever so it's a very
efficient way of storing we get in four
bytes of information we can know exactly
what an attribute is applied to so it's
quite efficient so efficiency is goal
number one
the other thing that's weird about these
tokens
is
well
so the the database
is weird because it doesn't exist at all
right then you press build the compiler
writes it out entirely stops writing it
and then nothing ever touches the
database ever again
and that assumption allows for more
optimization so for example metadata
tokens they always start at row number
one there are never any gaps
and there is a very well-defined order
for the rows in any table it's defined
in the spec
and so knowing that
the other weird trick about metadata
tables is these primary keys they don't
actually exist because you don't need
them you know the rows start at one you
know what table you're reading you can
compute any key I'm reading Row one
therefore the key is 0601 because I'm
reading the method table and so we get
efficiency Again by just not storing a
bunch of data which is really cool but
it will come up later
so remember that
you start to see these metadata tokens
and the type table figs everywhere
especially iSpy does a great job of
showing you so ieltspy is showing you
there so method is table six and there's
two rows in it that's where the brackets
are
the other place these tokens come up is
of course in our IL so IELTS by is
showing that this method calls
system.console.writeline
but that's IELTS by being nice really
what the IELTS is is there's the call
opcode which is you know some bytes that
maps to some enum somewhere that no one
no human can read and then there's
another four bytes which is the token
for what to call
this is again where our encoding our our
token type or our table name comes in
handy we could call a method defined in
this assembly we could call a method
defined in another assembly we don't
need to tell
we don't need to have separate IL
instructions for those two because the
token tells us what type of thing we're
doing so this is 0a
that's member ref so remember we can
Define things and we can reference
things they're stored separately so
member ref
why we went from method to member
doesn't matter
um ignore that I probably have said the
wrong word half the time so that's so we
so we're going to look up that table
it was row C this is all hex obviously
it was row C so we find that that's the
right line method it has a parent that's
a foreign key what does it point to
point to the type reference okay go look
that up well that's the console type
that has a resolution scope I don't know
call it what you want we looked that up
and that's in the assembly reference and
we that comes from system.console so
this is the level of detail that
metadata has right when you call
system.writeline
in your IDE you can hover over it you
can see it comes from the system
namespace we don't really in the IDE we
don't really expose the dll it comes
from but you can see it if you go
through properties
the metadata however doesn't show the
dll it shows the assembly name
but finding the dll is up to the runtime
and this is where you know we have type
forwarding and we have done at standard
versus.net thing and we look up Ms core
lib and the GAC and all that stuff all
that stuff is separate this is kind of a
thing that makes dot net dlls really
portable too because they encode
everything about what they're calling
right I am calling
system.console.writeline and I expect it
to be an assembly called system.console
but then I stop there and I don't care
where you find system.console and if you
find it because you have some weird you
know wasm compiled JavaScript ASM
whatever thing fund okay call my deal
right call My Method
um so that's really cool and that's
really powerful because it all came from
this one metadata token that says please
call oaoc whatever that means and the
runtime works it out
so how does hot reload work
glad you asked uh so hopefully remember
all that
that's the useful bit of the talk that's
the been talking maybe can like
you know go forth and use that knowledge
at work
maybe the rest not so much
I talk fast all right this is uh I'm
going to assume this is your conceptual
model of hot reload
uh obviously for the purposes of comedic
timing this is completely wrong but
we'll talk about it anyway
so logically speaking what happens we
write some code we start in the bottom
right but don't worry about that it's
just my PowerPoint skills
we write some code we compile it we send
it to the runtime the runtime runs it
but then we want to keep writing code
and we want to compile it again and we
send that off to the runtime
and the reason this doesn't happen or
the reason this isn't how hot reload
works is back to efficiency speed all
those things
if we had to compile your whole project
every time you changed code that would
be slow and you would complain
and if we were to give the runtime an
entire dll or set of dlls every time
then it would have a lot of work to do
to try to work out
you know what that means the thing to
the reason for this or thing to remember
about hot reload in this case is
it's not just applying the changes
but it's maintaining the state in your
application that's the hard bit right
just applying changes easy right that's
essentially like if you think about a
web browser you navigate you know deeply
through a web through a website if you
refresh the page you're still at that
page so you don't have to re-navigate
again but you've lost all of your state
and so it's not as much fun
so they're keeping the state to the hype
up
anyway so this is
more likely how hot it really works
so we start in the top left this time
confusingly so we write some code we
create a compilation great send it to
the runtime sure it was good
but now we edit some more code
and the first thing we have to do is we
have to work out what has changed
again right efficiency we only want to
compile the bits that we want we don't
want to compile the whole thing
and there's a bunch of fancy algorithms
in rolleston that do this
um there's uh was it longest common
subsequence I think it's called it's
like you open up the file on GitHub and
at the top it says this is from this
paper with a link to like a PDF and all
the variable names in it are like n and
K and L because that's what the paper
says and so therefore you cannot
understand a word of it but you just
don't trust it works and you move on but
so we have to work out what's changed
and we have to importantly we have to
work out what's changed from a.net
perspective right we're editing C sharp
we need to produce a.net assembly and
they are strictly separate and you know
you'll be editing vb.net
in theory you could be editing F sharp
although they don't support it because
Roslyn doesn't do F sharp but they could
and so we have to think about these
edits and we have to work out what's
changed in terms of net and that means
in terms of the metadata tables so when
I change a string in a method
uh Rosalind will Analyze That code and
it will use its syntax tree and it will
say ah you've changed a string literal
expression a little bit and that's part
of an expression and it basically walks
back up the tree until it hits a
boundary of Ah that's in a method.net
knows about methods so your edit in that
case is an edit to the method it doesn't
actually matter what you've done in the
method because if you think back to the
metadata tables not that I let you
Linger on the list of them but you know
there's no there's no metadata table for
line of code
there's no metadata table for you know a
block method is kind of the smallest
um well I guess fields are smaller but
anyway
so we work out what's changed
and we take our list of changes and we
tell the compiler hey go and compile a
Delta compilation
Delta meaning just the bits that have
changed and so our edit list is our
to-do list for the compiler
here's the whole project
but here's your bits you we want you to
compile
the compiler produces that Delta
compilation which is just metadata IL
disorders it's the same compiler it's
the same you know
same code path as compiling the full
delay we send that Delta to the runtime
and the runtime applies the delta
so the fact that it's a Delta meaning
it's just the changes means the runtime
doesn't have to work out what's changed
so it doesn't have to go and do any
magic So that's fast the fact that we're
telling the compiler what's changed so
it doesn't have to compile everything
that makes it faster right so that so
the linchpin is working out what has
changed and everything sort of flows
from there
the act of applying the delta
the way that I like to think about it is
so we have our relational database in
our metadata
and it's right once read-only never
changes all that stuff the runtime
essentially has a representation of that
in memory for each assembly and this is
what you query with reflection if you
think about reflection being a query API
over a relational database which
obviously no one would ever do but you
can this is kind of what you the
information you dig out when you say
give me the types and you say give me
the members so it finds that record in
the type table right then so give me the
members it goes looks up the member list
and that's another sort of like key to
understand this you can't say give me
the right line method and then read the
type of it it doesn't work that way
because the metadata doesn't work that
way you have to get the type first right
so
applying the Delta is basically
here's our compilation of what's changed
the kind of update statements
maybe it's a very long bow I'm drawing I
realized but
anyway let's work through an example
so here is a very small class
and it has three methods and here is our
method our method def table
for our Baseline Baseline is what we
call the you know the dll right the
thing you actually built
and so we have three rows now they're
tokens three four and five uh just for
illustrative purposes what is not shown
here is the Constructor again in C sharp
I don't need a Constructor but the
compilable synthesized one well that
means the compiler has to create a
Constructor and therefore it has to go
in the metadata.net does not have the
same assumptions as C sharp so the
Constructor is one and then I don't know
the main method for like you know
running the class I don't know doesn't
matter so they're ID three four and five
so we update method B
we we change the string Roslyn sees the
change to the string it goes right let
me work out what that is and we produce
an edit that says we have updated class
dot b
now actually class is probably a bad
name for this class because
the class there means the name of the
class sorry
uh so we have we have updated this uh
well I would call it a symbol that's a
bit of a Rosalind term but anyway
um this is the the thing we're updating
and so then we say hey compiler go
compile this type it'll go compile this
project here's your to-do list that's
right one item cluster B and so the
compiler produces a generation oh I
forgot to mention that every time
through the loop of of updating it's
called The Generation
so for generation one our Delta
compilation has a method def table that
looks like this
yes it doesn't make sense just wait
uh and so then we make another edit
we edit method a and Method B so in
version two of method a version three
and Method B our edits have disappeared
which doesn't matter but it just so
happens that we don't know the edits
after a generation has finished
um it doesn't really matter to the
process it just something I like to
complain about because it makes my job a
bit harder sometimes
so generation two we have two updates
Class A and Class B methods have been
updated and now we have a method def
table with two rows in it cool so
hopefully you can all see the very
obvious problem here
these IDs don't make any sense right if
we're thinking of this as an update
statement we have just ruined everything
because how did method be method B in
this one slide is id4 id1 and id2
clearly doesn't work
so
the the key to hot reload is there's a
little bit of information that the
compiler produces when it's producing a
Delta compilation that tells the runtime
how to apply these updates
and it's essentially
well it's not essentially it is a map
and it's a map of ID it's a map of
tokens
so
before I get into that
why are they one and two
I'm going to make this interactive does
anyone have a guess of why why is
generation one method B id1
correct first row so this is where the
fact that the tokens don't really exist
is important right there isn't actually
a
token that says method B is token one it
just so happens we've asked the compiler
to produce to compile one method it has
compiled one method and written one row
in our table
so when we read that table in it's Row
one so there's no way for us to say
in the method def table this is actually
row four
so we need this extra map
so the map where there's a map and
there's a log and it's a two two
metadata tables especially for hot
reload or for edit and continue ANC map
ANC log
and these are stored in the pdb which we
haven't talked about so pdb is we have a
metadata from our dll and a pdb is just
a bunch more data that's all it is and
it's just metadata there's no code in
there there's no IL pdb stands for
program
database thank you anyway
I'm not crazy I promise it's a
relationship so the pdb contains a bunch
of tables
and again thinking about efficiency
the tables in the metadata in the dll
are the ones that are required for the
runtime to run your code and everything
else is in the pdb because you don't
have to ship the pdbs
to run your code
but they are things that help you with
debugging scenarios like our reload and
it's also why pdbs are usually very big
because you know we try to keep as much
as possible out of the main dll so
there's things like the document table
the document table tells us the file
name for every method type you know
every well every sequence point which is
a thing
that's how we get nice stat traces and
that's how go to definition can work
sometimes right it's pulling data out of
that table we don't need to know what
file name things came from to run the
code but it helps in debugging we have
method debug information it's kind of
obvious we have Scopes because IL
doesn't have Scopes but breakpoints
local variables do we have custom debug
information which I love because it's
like I don't know if this is true but in
my mind they decided to name a bunch of
tables like oh we're going to store this
we're going to store this we're going to
see this we just want to store a bunch
of other stuff as well and we everything
goes in custom debug information great
but of course there's no ENT map and ANC
log so where is it well
there's a setting in IELTS by called
hide empty metadata tables
so you go and you turn that off
and now you can see a few more tables in
the pdb file we get State machine method
that's a good one state machine has data
about your async methods and your yield
your iterators because they become State
machines and so in order to debug and
step through these State machines we
have to know the information anyway
still no ANC log and NC map like well
yeah okay this is il spy it's looking at
a dll the Delta compilations never exist
on disk they don't like there's no such
thing as a Delta dll doesn't exist
so maybe that's why else why doesn't it
so you're going to look up the spec
you look up ecma 335 and you're like
David told me there was an ENC log table
and you search for it in the spec and
you find exactly one result
and it says yeah this is just used for
red LinkedIn you don't worry about it
if you're a conspiratory conspiratorial
person you think Microsoft's trying to
keep their secrets and stop jet brains
from using hot reload which is of course
right because jetbrain sports are reload
the reality is of course developers are
just really bad at documentation
and I say all this to to introduce the
next tool I'll spy I love our spy it's
very nice it looks very nice it's very
friendly once you can see past all of
the magic numbers and see them for the
tokens they are
but now we have to talk about mdv so mdv
is stands for metadata visualizer
and it was described to me with two
sentences
the first sentence was mdv is the only
tool you ever need to look at metadata
sounds good the second sentence was mdv
is designed for people who have read
ecma 335
I have not read Edmonton it's not
actually that bad it sounds scary than
it is but there's mdv you can go get it
you can install it.net tool
um in in a slighter side of conference
talk driven development up until last
week you couldn't install as a.net tool
but I had to get it on this machine and
it was so annoying building from source
that I made it all I also wanted to do
markdown output so I could show you the
results nicely but I ran out of time and
it probably wouldn't have got P I
wouldn't have got approved the people
who well
people who like mdv being for ecma 335
readers they also like that it's just
text and then it's raw like it's great
anyway
in 26 minutes the longest I've ever gone
without a demo any talk let's let's jump
to visual studio so this is
my little code snippet a b c now this is
a different project let me run it and
I'll show you so the I the tokens are
going to be different it's not going to
be four five and six I don't know what's
going to be we'll find out so this is
just a little program uh oh it doesn't
quite fit on the screen just a little
console app just runs a tight Loop and
runs these methods you can see the clock
here ticking away just to prove that
nothing's fake
it outputs what it outputs and on the
right here we have
essentially just looking in reflection
at what's in the program class this is
just outputting what's in reflection and
so
if I do my change to Method V2
and I press the hot relay button
we can see hello from B V2 has been
updated right a code's updated
no changes on the right hand side so
still only one method called B according
to reflection so we have successfully
hot reloaded well done everyone
uh and I'll now make my other change
that I said I would B3
and we can't relate
that worked too great
so scary pressing that button because if
it doesn't work
um so that's the demo obviously I
haven't shown you mdv yet that's because
I wanted to get both Generations out of
the way first
um actually I'm going to close this
so
in
Visual Studio
I have a special flag set
that dumps information like you know
diagnostic stuff about hot reload when
it does a hot reload and it dumps it to
this folder and I can see two that means
it's my second session of the day the
first session being in the previous talk
when I practiced to make sure this would
work and I can go into my app
and so here I have everything that hot
reload
produced normally this doesn't yeah I
said it doesn't exist on disk obviously
it does but you've got to sit this flag
so what we have here is we have our
at dll this is our Baseline right and
our pdb that matches it we have the
c-sharp files this is for you know
debugging roles and stuff we're not
going to worry about that plus you know
what it says because you saw me do it
and then we have for each generation we
have the IL Delta the metadata Delta and
the pdb Delta which is more metadata
and so we run mdv and it just goes and
it knows about this file structure so it
does stuff obviously I will not expect
you to read all of that so
let me do this
and open it up
and
are we good for size cool okay
so mdv dumps out everything it found so
the first thing it's going to dump out
is our Baseline right generation zero is
what it calls it Greater and so this is
just every metadata table so we have
type ref I love this because there are
there are 20 there's not 20 but you know
there's lots of rows of type riffs this
was a very small project it doesn't do
much but all these attributes for the
compiler has to eject whatever all that
has to exist in metadata I just love how
big it is
um and then we have type defs
so these are types defined right there's
a few attributes which the compiler
creates for us these are in basically
every dll this is my class that does the
reflection output thing but here's our
program class and interestingly if we
look over at the methods so
IL spices method list mdv says methods
ilspy gives you one token
excuse me mdv gives you a range
because of how the metadata tables work
and they're just like it's just raw
bytes and you have to know what you're
reading and oh I've got to the end
there's a count for each table so you
know how many rows to read and there's a
format for each table so you know how
many columns to read and you know all
this stuff so the names of these things
there's not a lot of like there's no
metadata about your metadata to make to
give a friendly name so mdv is being
nice and showing us the end
method for this type again that doesn't
really exist because you don't need it
because you read in all of the types now
you Loop through the types reading
methods and so you know when to stop so
anyway so so for our main class we go
from eight to C cool
our program class sorry as much fields
and then here we are here is our a b and
c
methods so where what are we nine A and
B okay fine we'll remember that here's
our synthesizer Constructor here's our
main method
um there's like lots of Constructors
great so that's cool eight nine and ten
great we can go down and we can see the
IL which
no I don't know whether this is going to
make any sense
nope nope nope there we are nope that's
not it hang on
ah I hate the fact that I can kind of
read the IL well actually I'm not I'm
reading the English there we go I'm not
reading the actual op codes I have no
idea what they do but so here's our
method a right because it says hello
from a he's a method B and you can see
we have metadata tokens here
um nine A and B so this is the IL for
this row so the IL is kind of like
another field but it's yeah stored
separately because it's big it can be
um cool so that's our Baseline so
generation one
here is our one method
so again there's no primary key written
down it's just that it happens to be the
first one
this is a problem
so
here is the magic right here's the ENC
log table here's the ENC map table
for the purposes of this demo for
updating a method we don't need both
they they're redundant they have the
same information but there's various
other scenarios where the log tells us a
bit more and the mat helps us out in
other ways like it's to help the runtime
but for updating a method
it's it's pretty straightforward and the
way this works which maybe you can
deduce
based on everything I said about how
metadata works and is red
again there's a distinct lack of
information in this as far as hey update
this method this says method def a
that's what it says that's all it says
right it's like what do I do with that
well it turns out this is the first
method def in the log therefore it's
method Def One
but it's really method if I and so
that's how that's how we tell the
runtime which one to update and then
same thing in the map this is the first
method def in the map a right the fact
that this is at the end here and this is
in the middle here is just because of
the spec of this table and they contain
different things it doesn't matter the
order is defined we know how it's going
to be written we know it'll never change
we know there won't be any gaps and so
we can make all of these assumptions and
the runtime has a bit of code that you
know if the compiler changes how this is
produced
it just things will just crash right
like everything will die but for now we
live in this wonderful world of
assumptions and everything works
um and that's basically I mean that's it
that's how hot really works like it's
it's for method updates anyway it's it's
kind of actually well I think
surprisingly simple we output a method
and then we say yeah that's that one and
then the runtime goes okay and it
updates all the data and in fact the
updating all the data is surprisingly
simple too because remember there's no
primary Keys all of these fields are
just data about method one which we now
know is Method a and so we just upload
all the data if we go further down
and we find some more IL here's IL from
B version two the IL actually has
the right method def already in it so we
don't even have to map that
right this is using the original uh
token
metadata to open for that method because
all of those Generations all of the or
the Baseline and the generations they
are all essentially in memory inside
Roslin while you're working and so when
it when we say hey compile method B
we go and look up
how how was method be defined now we
have to look it up and it's a little bit
complicated because of course you could
add a method in generation two so we
can't just go look in the Baseline
so sometimes we have to do a little bit
of math and go well it was added in two
and number 10 in the Baseline so that
means this is actually 11. and so
sometimes that gets a bit confusing but
you know again I'm the only one has to
worry about that and then here's our
generation two this looks much the same
we now have two methods one and two
we have two methods in our method ENC
log nine and a again it's the first
method Def and the second method def in
the log that's all it's all just based
on ordering
um and and and uh in a complete and
horribly anticlimactic talk that's how
what really works
um so I do have a couple more slides
because I tend to talk fast so that was
only 35 minutes actually not too bad I
think I do 40 in practice uh does anyone
have any questions about that what we've
got in more detail any
anything yes hello
yes so the question was when it sees the
number in the map does it just tell the
run time
to append to that number and essentially
yes what what the log is saying is I
mean it's called a log right it's a log
of what the compiler has done so with
the compiler is essentially saying I
have output a row for the method def
table
for token a
and
and so the runtime will then go and get
that row black motor
append versus update is is a good point
so in this case we're not appending
we're updating right so we're replacing
essentially replacing row 9A whatever it
is with a new one but you can sometimes
append because you can add new methods
and so the ENC log has another field
there which was all zeros in my example
and that zero means update and one means
add like it's in fact they're the only
two values I think and so sometimes we
say hey update the type
but we're adding a method and so then
for that
yeah we tell it the new token so we have
to work out what the next method in line
would be but then the runtime
has to go okay well if you're adding a
method
to this type and remembering that
everything has to be in order
right we now have to essentially roll
that new token forward through as we're
reading like the method that that method
list column right type A goes from one
to two and type B goes from three to
four but if we add a method to type a
well now the method list for type B has
to be changed so we tell it we're adding
and it rolls that foot
uh it rearranges the rows yes
essentially but
the same rules apply always in order no
gaps and and the order as defined in the
thing I could talk a bit about that
later
um really dumb question but it's been a
while since I've read ekma 335 yeah it's
been a few minutes for me too um
I remember that in the spec it actually
says that it's pointers into the various
heaps like the method bodies and things
like that
so I guess the dumb question is in terms
of hot reload wouldn't it be where you
just change the pointer into a different
say for example you want to change your
method body you just have it point to a
different stream and say here you go
here's a new method body for example
good question
um yeah so you could do that right
instead of updating row nine you could
just say you know what add on a row 10
because there's no validation other than
the fact that it has to be a valid
method exactly
um and in fact I can kind of demo this
later but we could have done that we
could say yeah add on a new row 10.
the problem with that goes back to state
if you have a delegate that points to
Method B
and I add on a new method B
where's your delicate point to what does
it run which version of the code and
there's so and you know you can probably
answer that for method delegates fine
but in terms of thinking about the state
of your application
adding new stuff is easy for the runtime
but you get a much better experience if
we can update all that stuff so what the
runtime will do like we've also like I
haven't talked about that method b gets
jetted when it gets run and then we have
tiered compilation now which just did
over and over again well of course if we
update it the runtime has to go and tell
legit yep throw out everything you do
about B start again right like there's
all sorts of flow-on effects here so it
could always just append
and in fact there are some scenarios so
uh Razer
um I don't know if you know this
hopefully you do Razer files are
generated into c-sharp backing files
and
in raise in some scenarios in Razer we
actually do essentially append
there's a flag that Razer tells the
compiler that says hey if you see any
changes to this type
don't worry about trying to update the
type just output an entirely new one and
so what was your razer backing class you
know Foo is now Foo underscore one
and the Razer run time the asp.net
runtime has to then go and do a bunch of
work to move all of its delegates and
Method pointers and model binding and
all of it stuff to say what I'm never I
forget about this class this is the new
one and it's a lot of work
so it's you know it razor asp.net can do
it because they know the the you know
the context of how they're running
there's they've probably got a list of
what supported what's not for the.net
runtime to do that in general
like you know there's a bigger breadth
of because I think the the part that's
missing here is that
yes it makes sense to update the tables
but if if this is being done in memory
I've seen other approaches where people
do a hot swap with delegates and things
like that yeah does that mean it
actually changes what's in memory and
how does that work with you know old
style where you have to get an app
domain you have to load it and unload it
and all the other stuff and how does
that work out
um
because you're not unloading it
obviously no you're you're using no what
did you get and you're changing the
pointers in memory so that it actually
works yeah I mean so so the the thing
about unloading a dll in app domains or
whatever that's
you know that's essentially a runtime
restriction
right so where hot reload we're not
we're not cheating right this is a
feature of the runtime so the fact that
they don't have to run the dll will they
own the fee they can yeah they can do
that and they can also say that you're
not allowed to unload a deal but they
are really they can totally do that so
we're not sort of cheating by trying to
patch memory or anything this is a
feature right there is an apply updates
method in the runtime which is called
and gets there's three streams of bytes
there's the IL stream the metadata
stream and the peer division like so
the way the runtime does it is is uh
it doesn't necessarily uh it's not
necessarily congruous with other things
in the runtime the other thing with hot
reload so I'm talking about hot reload
because it's the simplest scenario but
all of this code all of this the way
this works comes from edit and continue
which is why it's called ENC log edit
and continue is more complicated because
editing continue happens at an even more
granular level so if we talk about state
in edit and continue it maintains the
state of your local variables
right it maintains the state of which
statement in the method you're running
hot wheeler doesn't have to worry about
that and I didn't want to have to talk
about it so I didn't
but so
some of this stuff also it's like maybe
for hot reload it makes sense to do it
this other way but editing continue was
already doing it the hard way anyway and
so hot reload just Builds on that and
that's and last well last question is
where is this documented so for example
if I wanted to admit the IL for an
assembly
and without the compiler I just just
you're the compiler I know but but if
you wanted to
append it because for example if there's
like a small shim that you want to
generate and then you you is it just a
matter of changing that table
so
like I'm I'm just really curious as to
how you actually get to it in terms of
implementation yeah so this is where the
documentation is lacking so as far as
emitting the IL for the Delta it's just
an ecma 335 assembly essentially and it
has to follow all those same rules the
ENC log the NC map are sadly
undocumented
um but because I looked at that I was
like what's this yeah you would just
have to look at the code in Roslyn um
but I mean it's not it's also not very
exciting it is literally I output a
method I output at a time like it's
telling that it's just telecompiler it's
just what it did yeah
um if you come up after I can show you
there's tests in Roslin that sort of
maybe illustrate it pretty well
anyway any more questions yes Aaron
hello
I'm just going to move to annoy the
cameraman
so you showed a demo of that using it
with a console application is this
applicable for kind of anything that is
running on the.net runtime like an
asp.net application or good question
Windows forms and is it for
cross-platform or is it just a visual
studio thing so I'm going to answer that
by going to the next slide
because
kind of the second last dot point there
But to answer your question
at the start I said I'm talking about
applying changes to a.net assembly
and so therefore it applies anywhere
a.net assembly can be run
so
you know a.net assembly means via the
spec that it has these metadata tables
and therefore hot reload when it says
here's some new metadata tables well
that's what that means just on it and
it's got nothing to do with platforms
it's got nothing to do with things what
it does have to do with these runtimes
so I will jump forward in this slide so
why are some things not hot reloadable
why do root edits so this is just a list
of random examples of things that either
are or used to be root edits but they're
good examples of where in the process
the blockers can be so to answer your
question why do some things not work in
Blazer wasm
so Roslyn can detect all of your changes
in a blazerwasm server a Blazer wasm not
server
um project the compiler can happily
compile all of the metadata tables that
it needs to to do all of the changes for
a blazerwasm project and in fact
you know the Blazer runtime will
download that dll if necessary right
like all of these things are essentially
uh Universal what's different
specifically with blazer wasm is the
runtime blazerwasm uses the mono runtime
and so that step in the process where we
give the Delta to the runtime the mono
runtime does not have the same feature
set as far as how as far as which things
in the ENC log it knows how to process
so the mono runtime can only do at the
moment method body updates that's it
so you can modify methods you can't add
new ones you can't add Fields you can
add properties you can't change field
initializers like there's a bunch of
limits and there's this there's an API
for the runtime to tell Roslyn what it
can support So Roslyn can report a root
edit in a Blazer wasm that would work in
a donut
standard.net6 Library so we know about
what the runtime limitations are and
they're working on getting mono more
support like seriously there's like
people working on it but so that's where
the limitations come in at the runtime
level so all of this is produced as per
the spec and here's the things but some
runtimes don't have all the capabilities
and so that's one reason you might get
root edits and obviously blazerwasm it's
a pretty big blocker at the moment
because it does limit what you can do so
some other reasons for root edits why
couldn't you update records so this
one's past tense because you can now
because I do the work
um so one of the blockers is
that whole thing of working out the
changes and mapping the changes back to
a.netism from a c-sharpism means add and
continue
which is what the classes are called in
Roslin slash hot reload has to be taught
about every single C sharp feature now
some of them well some of them it
doesn't actually have to be taught about
right like the fact that you can now do
a ref or an in parameter doesn't care
because that doesn't sort of that
doesn't escape out to the metadata world
at all that's a compiler thing but for
things like records we have to teach
Roslyn okay if they add a new record
here's what it means or can they add a
new record right if they update a record
so for example if you add a field to a
record
versus adding a field to a class adding
field to a class one New Field adding
field to a record one New Field change
the Constructor change the copy
Constructor change the equals method the
get hash code method the print members
method Rosalind has to know all of that
so that he can tell the compiler these
are all the methods you have to Omit so
that it can put them all in the meta
like so we have to teach it all about
all the um the c-sharp features now the
compiler devs are supposed to do this
some of the big ones they leave it for
us and we do it we do a pass at the end
um and so well the reason for the root
edits is the easiest way to teach Roslyn
about a new compiler feature is to say
if you see this new compiler feature
it's a rooted lad ticks the Box
um so that's number one uh why couldn't
you update attributes and I think yes
this so This goes back to what you were
asking about appending versus updating
so attributes are interesting because
they point back to the table they come
from more like a normal uh you know
database
but the rules of ecma 335 say that the
attribute table has to be ordered by the
parent column which is the column that
points to where it was so if I add a new
attribute to a method I might have
attribute for method one attribute for
method two attribute for a property
attribute for a type
but if I want to add a method I have to
insert a row between two
because the ordering has to be
maintained
but that's going to affect all of the
tokens for all of my other attributes
right so excuse me the the way to fix
this or the reason this was a root edit
and the way we fix this is we added the
capability or the smart to the compiler
that when it's emitting a Delta
compilation it now knows how to Output
the custom attribute table in a way that
the runtime will accept and this is also
some that in this case we didn't have to
in the end but we the way this project
started was we went and got talked to
the runtime devs and say hey how can we
do this right like what do you need to
know from us to be able to update this
table and it turned out they didn't
actually need anything from us if we
could just do it on the rosin side and
essentially every time there's a
generation we just re-output the entire
custom attribute table and actually
that's one of the benefits of this token
system the row is not special that it
points to a method or a property
whatever it's just a bit of data and so
we just clobber right this row used to
point to a property great points to a
method now bad luck and so you add a
method we want to insert a method you
know in between rows two and three well
actually we just insert a method at the
end which the runtime can handle but we
rewrite all of the other methods
so sometimes it's teaching the compiler
New Tricks
um why couldn't you add a weight and
yield return so this is that state
machine table in metadata it just didn't
have enough information
so async methods become a state machine
which means for every await in your
method there's a new state so one two
three four
when you hot reload we need to remember
what state you're up to but of course if
you add in a weight above where you are
then we have to change this one for us
now it's not not State four anymore it's
our state five and so that information
is now in this new uh or not in it's in
the pdb so sometimes it's writing more
data to the B2B Blazer where's the
runtime and then generic types is the
big one I honestly don't know if this
will ever be fixed because this is a
huge runtime limitation the whole type
system of.net is affected if we ever
have to change this and so sometimes we
get these things like
yeah I don't know maybe we maybe we
can't do that maybe we can I don't know
um all right we have 10 more minutes
I'm now going to commit crimes I love
Hot reload because you can commit crimes
this is my favorite demo I love it
where's Visual Studio
okay
I'm going to run this code
run this app
and here is this is kind of also back to
the appending stuff right so here's my
code great I've got my three methods in
reflection no problem I'm just going to
delete that one
and I'll reload
now what happened there is we called C
and something went wrong
and now this code this this class you
know it has catches the exception it
runs again you can see the clock is
still ticking right it's still running
it's not fake
and there's still a method C in
reflection
so the run time does not support
deleting methods
but we on the wrestling team we get
Telemetry about root edits so we know
you know any in the last seven days I
can tell you how many times people ran
into root edit number 423 or whatever
and one of the common ones is well one
of the common ones is is changing method
signatures
but then in designing the feature it
boils down to deleting members is part
of it
but so we wanted to be able to delete
methods even though the runtime can't
and so we decided that we didn't care
that the runtime can't and so what
happens is you delete a method and in
the compiler there's a little bit of
code that says oh you think you deleted
that method no no you updated that
method but its body now says throw new
Missing Method exception
so we cheat right
normally
this wouldn't be a problem the reason
this is committing crimes is because if
I scroll up you'll see there's a compile
area here
right C doesn't exist the compiler
doesn't know how to compile this method
but because we produced our list of
edits and I didn't touch this method no
one asked the compilative part of this
method so we didn't
so there's a bit of Il that says call
method nine and Method nine still exists
it just has one line of code and it says
throw numeracy I love it I love it so
much and I can put it back
and that works and now we're back to
calling C again and so the whole point
of this hot reload is at runtime yeah
that was really weird things threw up
blew up in ways that you definitely
weren't expecting right there's no way
that all of your code has try catches
that says catch Missing Method exception
just in case someone deletes it at Dev
time but the point is
if you are a little bit resilient with
your code somewhere
I didn't have to restart my app and
that's the point of hot reload right is
and that's what we want to do is
getting rid of the root edits maybe it
doesn't make
things work exactly the way you expect
them to but you at least don't have to
restart your app so all of your state is
still there I can do
cool things like return a string
so if I do this I think this is going to
work but boy it might blow up
it worked okay
so this one is so so that was changing
method signature right
and the reason we did deleting methods
is because changing methods is built on
top of deleting methods deleting methods
is like the key to all of this
what happened is
I changed method C from void returning
to string returning and logically
speaking as humans we see that as the
same method but I change the return type
and C sharp doesn't let you distinguish
methods by return type but dot net
absolutely does and so that's what we
did so when you update the return type
or add a parameter or change of
parameter type or rename a method we
delete the old one throw a Missing
Method exception which is what you're
seeing there and then we insert a new
one which has the same name and a
different return type and that's totally
fine it's fine
as far as metadata is concerned and so
now we can see on the right here I have
two methods
one is this one is going to be you know
inactive right this one's going to throw
an exception this one's active if I uh
reverse this
and I'll reel it again now we're back to
calling C and we're happy still only two
methods but now and you can't see this
you have to trust me the one that
returns a string that one now throws a
Missing Method exception and we are
working with the runtime and hopefully
we'll have some way to flag to them that
we've done this crime and then they can
make reflection you know reflect that
fact or maybe they just will skip over
it like yeah make it all make sense in
general though if you're using
reflection
like and hot reload kind of all bets are
off so you know sorry but there's only
so much we can do
um
anyway I love that demo
oh and this is still on top so that is
really the end of the talk so does
anyone really have any questions or you
can go get I guess lunch
yes hello we'll wait for the mark hang
on wait because the method was never
cleaned up so not that it would be a
real problem but if you did hot reload
three or four times you'd have a lot of
junk methods to be sitting in the
assembly room yeah so
um that's true did they if you keep
changing the method signature over and
over again to new ones every time then
there will be detritus of methods left
behind but we are clever and we try to
reuse them where we can like if the
signature matches so if you resurrect
one we will resurrect it where this gets
cool is properties and events because
properties so what you think of a
property
is not really a property it's two
methods in a trench coat and so when you
change the return of the type of a
property we output a new get method a
new set method so we have two to four
and then you change it again now we have
six and uh events if you're using VB are
three methods in a trench coat because
there's an ad to remove and array C
sharp doesn't have rays but of
course.net has to have rays and Roslyn
has to therefore understand rays and I
have to write VB code in order to make
that work and I really hate myself uh
any I think there was another question
here once uh thank you all right let's
start from Modern runtime
was runtime Rewritten in.net6 I only saw
modern runtime and something related to
Omni sharp and to connect no I mean
dotnet6 has its traces the Terrace Edge
back a long way it wasn't a rewrite
of.net framework or anything but I mean
edit and continue has been in like
within.net framework very early on so
the the bones of all of this have been
there and in.net 6 with hot reload being
you know the marketing hot reload of
xaml and xamarin and all of those things
um it got a bunch of yeah it was good
because it funded a bunch of work and so
I got a bunch more smarts around it
um
things like you can create a class in
your assembly and tag it with an
attribute and then after a hot reload
occurs the runtime will call your code
and tell you which types were changed
which is how asp.net does its whole hey
there's a new view for this and so you
can actually make your code work or your
application work better with hot reload
by maybe there's some cache that you
need to invalidate it's like I've got a
little train game
and it's very like it's written terribly
so in order to get decent performance I
catch a lot of stuff so you draw out the
tracks
and then I save that image of what those
tracks look like and I never draw it
again but of course when I hot reload
that's now a problem so I have a little
thing and I tag it with the attribute
and I invalidate my cache every time I
do a hot reload and now my Dev Loop
while I'm working on my project is a bit
better so the runtime does get new
features and stuff but yeah all of this
stuff traces its lineage back to edit
and continue back into our Net Framework
whatever it was I was saying this
because I think you mentioned there was
something that modern runtime couldn't
do and the mono runtime so mono is the
runtime used in laser wasm and it only
supports method body updates at the
moment
um but they are actively working on like
uh it it also now supports Lambda
updates which are really just method
body updates but in a separate type and
so there's a bunch of work that has been
done it's not quite sort of visible to
us as users yet when they get to like
add new field add new property that's
when the majority of the root edits
should hopefully Fall Away
cool
so you actually started answering my
other question uh so for example I when
using how to load I realized an esp.net
specifically there are certain areas
that
struggle one area kind of makes sense if
you have something in the startup
registrations
some other things like for example if
you modify an auto mapper mapping
something like that that also doesn't
get picked up yeah so that's a very good
question and a good point I probably
should have mentioned but I didn't but I
wouldn't know
hot reload updates your code
so when you change your startup class I
can promise you hot reload is updating
that startup plus the problem is
nothing ever calls that to be run again
right that's my why my console app has a
loop it says a while through because I
can apply the same hot reloads but if
nothing runs the new code or the old
code or whatever then you don't see the
changes so things like startup classes
automapa
um
that's up to asp.net to work out how
they're going to do that so they they
can put that attribute on and they can
somehow call startup again but without
breaking the world I don't know but
that's
that's up to them so is there anything
actually that is available to real-end
users to for example say
when I change this just restart to think
for me instead of me pressing Ctrl C
Ctrl R
um
for the web specifically I don't know in
general like is there for example an
attribute put attribute on these classes
and if it changes
yeah so so you would write a class that
you put the attribute on and then that
class knows how to do whatever so it
gets called when there's a change
but you have we would have to write the
smarts for what to do to react to that
change
we should probably let these people go
get lunch before the queue gets big but
I'm happy to talk afterwards if you want
uh thank you everybody
[Applause]